frozen was the biggest animated hit of
all time how did you have the guts to to
take on another part okay yeah we
it was interesting was about a year
after the film we were doing a short and
we saw the Manta maiden and we got
emotional and we realize we missed them
and Peter had been traveling the world
our producer and a lot of people could a
kept asking why does also have powers
what what's what's what's next for Ana
where would the parents going and we
were having we had the same questions
and then we just got we looked at each
other like all right can we let's do
this again but but we were excited about
the journey that we thought that they
could have you know what we looked at
the end of the first film is sort of a
graduation day the happy ending but the
world was now open to them and so what
does that mean you know where are they
gonna go the path they're gonna find and
and what do they have to give the world
so that goes I knew that we wouldn't do
it unless Bobby and Kristen would come
along for the ride and thankfully we
still remember the little unofficial
week before it was announcing like you
didn't hear it from me but this Jeep is
force like hey guys look what and she
was like I think we have a story for
frozen too and talking about today I
realized how meta it was because we were
literally all feeling this call that
there was more to know and we were all
stepping into the unknown together it
really was this when people are asking
us to talk about into the unknown and
the what what inspire it into the
unknown and I was like it's because we
were with a matching water bottle guys
how the real pointed stars the do a
sticks anymore I'm sorry too
one to tell you but we can't do plastic
spring are and they have to match and
they have to match thank you I'm sorry
Kristen you were talking I was just
basically saying we were all like they
were like how did you guys come up with
the story and we say everything happens
with chris buck jennifer lee like we
there's no song before the story has
inspired us but then i realized the
story was our story we were all stepping
into the unknown together and we were
all feeling this sort of maybe we should
and by the time you start engaging with
the idea of actually doing it before you
know it you're doing it which is the
first animated musical sequel that's
what we have heard that dis animation is
that we've done the original is based on
Hans Christian Andersen's Snow Queen and
at the same time this to my knowledge
isn't part of so you're basically
creating an original sequel which is
something I usually the sequel feels
like you've seen the first movie and now
you're seeing it again this is
incredibly different so where did all
this come from
well I think we knew the only reason to
do this as if we were evolving if this
is for us was not this was sort of
chapter two then this was them we wanted
to look at change we all know the day if
we say happily ever after but we know
change happens in life the sisters are
now together but Elsa has these powers
seeing them mature and grow up was what
really mattered to us and telling that
journey it it wasn't about looking back
and and so we knew if we were going to
confront Elsa's powers it's going to get
bigger the idea that she will go up
against in life you go up against
obstacles you don't know how to face and
really keeping that metaphor of of
growing up and change throughout and and
that's we went into it that way and
there's so much we found along the way
we took many routes but found that just
kept Sri supporting these sisters and
this inner strength they have that I
don't even think we knew how how big it
was and and we're proud of
we're proud of them they kind of told us
where they wanted to go and they think
they were willing to do a lot because
you talked about how you decide what to
type of song and what placement of song
well it all starts with story and we we
work very closely with with Jen and
Chris and there's the story team at
Disney sometimes every day we would have
a call and just talking through the
story they would pitch us things that
they'd come up with in the interim and
we would we would always have a little
bit of fresher ears because we would
then forget everything then until the
next day so we sometimes we'd have ideas
that we're totally irrelevant and
sometimes they would help but but really
what we're looking for our places where
a character is faced with the decision
and the emotion is so high that they
can't really talk anymore they have to
break into song and at by the end of the
song that there's been a there's been a
climax and something has changed
irrevocably so so that's what we're
looking for in every single one and it
never gets easier but but we all kind of
hack at it together until we until we
get it sometimes we submit half of a
song and they they give us feedback
about that sometimes they give us
artistic inspiration to be beautiful
beautiful artwork that helps us finish
the song or helps us take it to the to
the right direction and just speak to
your sort of there's an eclecticism to
this score and that's every the thing
that can that unifies all of these songs
is they're all about change in the first
movie that we were also using that
eclectic than by eclectic fancy word
means like you jump through different
genres there's it's not just like all
one type of song that the first movie
was all every song had to do with love
this one every song has to do with
change in some way and each character is
having to go through their own personal
journey to lead to growth so in the case
of Olaf Olaf Olaf tends to lend himself
to sort of old vaudeville there's a
innocence and a naivete to that music
and Olaf tends to sing in sort of that
vaudeville kind of way
whereas Christoph who we get to hear
from for the first time in this whole
movie Christophe we were looking for
what what how could he sing the biggest
most passionate feelings in a way that
would work and we actually worked with
these guys to find a way to allow us to
go into a stylized 80s power ballad and
really sing like the power ballads that
I used to listen to when my boyfriend's
broke up with me when I was 15 and you
know and if you get one thing from
Christoph song I hope you get the
permission to feel all your feelings in
the biggest 80s way Kristen and Adina
I'm just curious about your work
together and how you work to create
different characters and at the same
time create that sisterhood do you you
do you get to record together first of
all and sometimes one time in the first
movie was that did we record in a second
movie together yes I remember lullaby
lullaby of course I know what you're
doing when you said that um well we look
when I first met Adina I was asked to go
to her house and prepare a duet that we
would sing for some Disney executives in
a boardroom at the animation building
and I even though we're Adina hit
Broadway at such a young age and I was
watching her going oh my lord this is my
idol this is the the girl and so when I
was told to go to her house and sing at
her piano I was like I couldn't breathe
and I walked in and my palms were sweaty
and I was doing exactly what Onawa do
when I was talking too much and I was
like I'm so nervous I feel like I'm
gonna puke
she just put her hand on my shoulder and
she was like you sound beautiful this is
gonna be great and it was it was exactly
what my older sisters do to me and I
have siblings and it was it was like
perfect from the moment we met and I
think in you know in the movie its
representative of the siblings that I'm
not exactly like my sisters at all in
fact we're very different but there's
something about being cut from the same
cloth it's you know could have something
to do about sharing the same DNA but if
you grow up in the same household that's
just as good but there's something that
Bond's you there are you know what Edina
had been bringing up earlier was this
idea of what we were so proud of we did
we uncovered and discovered self-love
and familial love in the first film and
that's what made us so proud because
almost all other movies are about
romantic love and that's not bad it's
just I personally I think that self-love
and familial love are important to hit
before you get to romantic love and yeah
I I love working with Edina yeah and I
love working with Kristen and I think
well what we really love about being
able to play these sisters is this
fierce loyalty they have for one another
and and how they would do anything for
each other and how they actually really
more than anything want the other one to
feel fully realized in their life and
that they're pursuing their passion and
that whatever it is that they find their
purpose in life and they're authentic
reason for living and and it's just it's
just pure thing that I mean I feel that
way in real life she's very supportive
of me and she reminds me of my younger
sister who's like three and a half years
younger than me and who is sort of an
old soul and I just finally chrysalis so
wise and so eloquent and I often look to
her my sister got married first and she
had babies first and it's the same thing
I I constantly I look to my sister when
I'm going through a crisis and I would
do the same if it was was Kirsten I feel
like I look up to her in a lot of ways
so it's easy the job is easy that's all
right
stardancer but I will say that one last
thing is it it is this to me this
beautiful reminder and I don't think
everybody gets this and we certainly as
human beings on planet Earth forget this
every day you don't have to agree with
everyone to love them we're supposed to
be different you know it's like they're
the same as Voltaire quote I may not
believe in what you say but I'll fight
to the death for your right to say it we
are not supposed to be carbon copies of
each other so the sisters are very
different and they argue in this film
and they if they'd have disagreements
but they're the fierce loyalty comes
from this undercurrent of love and it is
okay to disagree with the people that
you love thank you all for putting this
together and I think the audience had a
great time today